In Myanmar, Aung San Suu Kyi's democracy movement...
...takes power after 50 years of military rule,...
...with a close aide of the Nobel Laureate sworn in as president.
In Switzerland, UN chief Ban Ki-moon calls for a united global effort...
...to tackle the Syrian refugee crisis.
In Cyprus, a court orders the suspect in the EgyptAir hijacking...
...be held in custody for eight days pending an investigation.
In the US, Donald Trump's anti-immigrant rhetoric...
...drives many Latinos to apply for citizenship...
...to try and prevent the Republican front-runner from becoming president...
...if he wins the nomination.
And finally, the number of foreign visitors traveling to Turkey...
...dropped ten percent in February over security concerns,...
...its biggest drop in a decade.